ce soir notre invité principal c'est
charles pasqua
certains sports bonsoir jurés vous de
dire la vérité toute la vérité rien que
la vérité non
vous êtes sénateur des hauts-de-seine je
rappelle que le sénat c'est cette jolie
maison de retraite qui est près de
l'odéon non c'est un club très simple
année c'est le seul club de paris où
l'on est payé avec amp y payer vous êtes
payés 11500 40 euros par mois + 1000
euros de primes informatique en fait
vous pouvez acheter un mac tous les
moins quoi hein et le budget du sénat
comme c'est beaucoup à ses 300 millions
d'euros par an quand même hein je suis d
de l'assemblée de combien sauf que
s'élancent demande un peu à quoi ça sert
des fois non vous avez tort c'est une
maison sérieuse elle point de vue du
travail la qualité supérieure à celui de
l'assemblée nationale les lois quand
elles sortent de chez vous elles ont été
véritablement étudié sous tous leurs
aspects et peaufiné d'accord
[Applaudissements]
sénateur des hauts-de-seine charles est
pourquoi les hauts-de-seine à cause du
climat
celloises la whey en tout cas c'est pas
du tout l'accent des hauts-de-seine il
n'y a pas il n'y a pas d'actions propres
trains mais pourquoi vous avez gardé
l'accent assez pour que les français
vous m avez les casseroles que vous avez
changé mais
je n'ai fait aucun effort pour le perdre
aïe ça vous rend sympathique un oui ça
fait oublier un peu les casseroles enfin
c'est vous c'est pas les casseroles
c'est une quincaillerie
donc camper un char nous parlerons de
vous et de votre livre ce que je sais
aux éditions du seuil le tome 2 de vos
mémoires politiques et passionnant et
très précis alors c'est marrant parce
que vous souvenez de tout un cc c'est
phénoménal il ya que devant un juge ou
vous vous souvenez de rien a su
me souviens de tout aussi se souvient
d'un léger a eu d'accord
alors sans pasqua quoi bon soir ce qui
est très paradoxale avec vous c'est
qu'aux yeux de beaucoup de français vous
incarnez l'homme politique madre voir
roublard qui a toujours su échapper aux
diverses informations judiciaires
déclenchées contre lui c'est que vous
êtes quand même record de man de france
des mises en examen qui n'ont jamais
débouché je crois que je crois que c'est
vous peut-être
peut-être
enfin vous incarnez quand même une sorte
de parrain de la politique et quand on
connaît votre vie un petit peu on sait
que j'étais dans la résistance à l'âge
de 15 ans militant gaulliste luttons
contre contre les nazis comment jean
moulin est il devenu donne corleone
c'est trop facile de dire ça mais son
refus serait peut être ouais c'est
arrivé malheureusement creuse ouais
j'aurais pu l'être tout autant j'aurais
pu être d'ailleurs je le suis resté un
peu par donc ça le vent ça ne se voit
pas tellement mais je suis à cesana
vous êtes né en 1927 si vous fait 82 ans
et j'aimerais
une famille corse une famille modeste
votre grand père était berger en corse
votre père est venu en métropole il
devenu officier de la paix votre mère
corse aussi était ouvrière dans une
usine de parfum à grasse donc une
famille modeste patriotes proches du
front populaire et quand pétain est
arrivé votre père a refusé de prêter
serment à l'état français il apprend
qu'à londres un certain général de
gaulle appelle à la poursuite du combat
et là toute la famille entre dans la
résistance et vous aussi à 15 ans oui
parce que mon oncle avait été arrêté
nous à 15 ans au bâti les armes à la
main rennes donc votre engagement vous
vos la carte
5755 des combattants volontaires de la
résistance et la médaille de la france
libre
alors après la guerre vont rester fidèle
à de gaulle à qui vous vous est un
véritable culte vous êtes dit je suis
prêt à mourir pour lui et cette phrase
extraordinaire s'il avait été tito oui
je serais devenu communiste est-allemand
c'était plus un attachement à deux
boules qu'à une idéologie pour ce qu'il
représentait moins de gaulle c'était la
france éternelle ouais puis c'était la
france dessus des partis etc alors après
de gaulle effectivement là vous êtes un
peu orphelin vous cherchez un père vous
cherchez un un partenaire dans un
premier temps vous croyez le trouver en
chirac
vous imaginez pour chirac un destin
national qu'il aura d'ailleurs fictive
mais revenons en fait celui que je sous
la halle en reniant la promesse qu'il
vous avait fait de maintenir le cap du
gaullisme en fait voilà en fait c'est un
rad soc quoi oui radical socialiste
comme son père se rendre sur coin
corrézien corrézien voilà ouais à l'est
des côtes est extrêmement sympathique
dans l'opération sert à la louche il est
le plus
rappelle
le parcours électoraux il pas avertis
qu'ils aient dit [ __ ] et lui lui
répond jacques chirac
ah oui oui c'est différent une biche au
hasard lui bourrer ouais quand même en
tout cas sur chirac vous dit quand même
que c'est beaucoup de temps perdu pour
la france vous n'êtes pas tendre avec
lui dans votre bouquin jamais tendres
pour les gens qu'on a beaucoup aimé vous
a déçu on vous dit qu'il est
irresponsable mystificateur que
l'élection de 95 a été une supercherie
vous parlez d'opportunisme de
pusillanimité de d'un règlement il on
vous l'avait beaucoup aimé parce que là
vous êtes très dur avec lui quand même
qu'elles viennent chatouiller assez
clair alors vous avez été donc déçu par
chirac et puis ensuite par tout ce que
vous avez choisi pour oublier de gaulle
sauf ce gars ah oui ce gars il vous
plait bien c'est le seul qui ait gardé
cette sensibilité à la fois le contact
populaire et aussi la volonté de faire
bouger les choses ouais parce que
balladur bon c'est pas vraiment un homme
d'état ouais et de villiers à la fin
vous n'êtes pas dire que dans votre
recherche de deux paires après de gaulle
faisait très peu après mme c est terminé
avec philippe de villiers quand même
annoncé lui qui cherchait à perdre
alors vous vous retrouvez en fait seuls
10 la personne qui trouve grâce à vos
yeux et là vous pensez à vous présenter
vous même vous dire après tout pourquoi
pas charles pasqua c'est vrai qu'à un
moment c'était assez crédible hypothèse
est là dit vous vous emmerde commence
parce que après la percée aux
européennes en 99 vous commencé à
menacer chirac pour la présidentielle de
2002 et vous dites que là quand même on
a commencé à vous chercher des poux dans
la tête
j'ai été ministre de l'intérieur
alors je ne crois pas aux coïncidences
ce qui est marrant avec vous c'est qu'on
croit que en fait vous avez des dossiers
sur tout le monde mais vous êtes est
persuadé que tout le monde avait bien
sûr vous aussi
je n'ai de dossiers sur personne avant
c'était une grappe de blague oui c'est
normal mais qui vous en suis arrivée qui
vous a fait quand
je suis arrivé au ministère de
l'intérieur en 86 je m'amusais beaucoup
de la crédulité des gens alors surtout
qu'à paris un certain nombre de
personnages débattu vie qui vous disent
pas bonjour puis tout d'un coup vous
avez un procès c'est pas cher ami
commenta lien ou etc
et alors certains incertaine cela
lorsqu'il se présentait comme ça chers
amis comment allez vous alors quand il
verra main tendue comme ça je disais
depuis que j'ai lu votre fiche je ne
peux plus beau sera là bas
on à faire encore commencé l'angolagate
à 100 je me suis toujours demandé ce que
vous n'êtes pas responsable des ventes
d'armes à l'angola votre fils non plus
non plus non plus alors vous dites c'est
yves bertrand en fait caca qui aiment
magouilles et les choses et c'est vrai
donc quand on voit les carnets de diy
bertrand ex patron des rg c'est vrai que
c'est surréaliste quoi je vois ce que ce
mec-là été capable d'inventer pour nuire
aux gens ont quand même un oui ça c'est
clair a pu alors de surcroît pour
quelqu'un qui était chef de service de
contre-espionnage
passé sont a écrit
alors que moi je me souviens qu'elle
j'ai commencé très jeune dans les
services d'enseignement la règle de base
que nous disaient les instructeurs en
même temps c'est très relative en scène
c'était qui pioncent y crête en crête
bah oui bien des secrets vous dit de
toute façon vous dites je n'ai honte de
rien je ne me repens de rien de rien la
repentance c'est pas votre truc là
sérieusement vous n'êtes pas inquiet
quand même de l'image que vous avez
laissé à la postérité oui mais vous
savez on ne peut pas faire une carrière
politique sans que y est un certain
nombre d'amis crochet d'aller à 1 mais
je pense que les français
dans le fond ne s'y trompe pas ouais
vous avez quand même bien fait deux
trois conneries charles comme un homme
dont on fait tous lesquelles ces pages
où le monde dont je n'ai pas le
sentiment
d'être sympa le jugement dernier avec
vous ça n'a pas duré longtemps en fait
tout est sonné ce quad et quand je
regarde ce que j'étais tout ce que j'ai
fait ce que je suis devenu je n'ai pas
de regrets à avoir j'ai eu à prendre des
décisions
lourdes de sens l'arrestation des gens
d'action directe ça aurait pu très mal
se terminer
l'école maternelle de neuilly pareil
l'airbus d'air france algérie cette idée
là au moment où vous prenez la décision
vous devez savoir que vous êtes tout
seul
personne
[Applaudissements]
est publié aux éditions du seuil ça
s'appelle ce que je sais trois petits
points ça veut dire que vous en garder
un peu sous le coude il ya des choses
que je ne dirai jamais ouais il ya des
choses qui sont couvertes par ce que je
considère moi comme étant la raison
d'état des choses qu'on n'a pas à dire
voilà
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus